هزه بقوه اربع درجات فاصله اربعه في اعماق
البحر المتوسط يرتد صباح في تركيا ولبنان
والاراضي الفلسطينيه
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه تؤكد صد هجمات
الروسيه عنيفه قبل يومين من ذكرى بدء
الحرب
وسط سباق في التسلح الصين واليابان اول
محادثات امنيه رسميه منذ اربع سنوات
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم مشاهدينا بكل خير واهلا
بكم في هذه النشره الجديده والمفصله من
العربيه نبدا النشاط اذا من اخبار زلزال
في تركيا حيث اعلنت اداره الكوارث التركيه
عن حدوث هزه اعتداديه جديده بقوه اربع
درجات فاصله واحده على مقياس ريختر في
كهرمان مرعش كما اعلن المركز الامريكي
للزلازل من جهته عن تسجيل هزه ارتداديه
بقوه اربع درجات فاصله اربعه على سلم
الاختر وتم تسجيل مركزها في اعماق البحر
المتوسط قبره لبنان مواطنون من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل احس بالهزه العنيفه
وفي ايران تم الاعلان عن هزه بقوه خمس
درجات فاصله خمسه بمقياس ريختر ضربت مناطق
بمحافظه فارس جنوب غرب البلاد هذا ولم
يتضح بعد ما اذا كانت هناك علاقه بين هذه
الهزات الارضيه التي تم الاعلان عنها في
عده دول في وقت متزامن
هذا وتواصل السلطات التركيه احتواء
التبعات سلسله الزلازل والهزات التي ضربت
البلاد طيله الاسبوعين الماضيين اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد اعلنت انها
نصبت اكثر من 300 الف خيمه في الولايات
المتضرره من زلزال كهرمان مرعش جنوبي
البلاد واشهر بيان اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه انه جرى اقامه مخيمات في 270 نقطه
الاقل في الولايات
انها تلبي الطلبات الفرديه ايضا للخيام
هزه ارضيه في هاتايا التركيه اكملت تدمير
ما تضرر من مباني في الزلزال الاول قوتها
كانت 6.3 على سلم
سته الاف هزه ارضيه واكثر خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين ضربت جنوبيه تركيا وشماليه سوريا
منذ اول زلزالين في السادس من فبراير
الحالي
كل الارتدادات التي ضربت تركيا وسوريا
والبلدان القريبه كانت عند الاربع درجات
على سلم ريختار الا ان زلزال امس فقد ست
درجات الامر الذي اثار تساؤلات حول ماهيته
هل هي هزه ارتداديه ام انه زلزال اخر
علميا حسب هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه
تكون الهزات الارتداديه اقل قوه من
الزلزال الرئيسي وتتناقص تدريجيا الى ان
تنتهي هذا يدل ان المنطقه المنكوبه هي في
ذروه النشاط الزلزالي
الهيئه الامريكيه اكدت ان الزلزال الاول
في غاز عنتاب تسبب في كسر على الفالق
الزلزالي طوله يصل الى 350 كيلومترا
ويتطلب هذا النوع من الكسور الى وقت طويل
لكي يلتئم وبالتالي يجب توقع حدوث هزات
اخرى
الاخبار الكاذبه والتنبؤات غير العلميه
التي انتشرت عبر وسائل التواصل اثارت ضجه
وزادت مخاوف الجمهور لكن هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه نفت بشكل قاطع قدره
التنبؤ بالزلازل الكبيره
انس النماسي العربيه
ومنها طيب مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مفدى
العربيه عبد القادر خربوش اهلا بك عبد
القادر وهل شعرتم بهذه الهزه الجديده
اليوم في هاتاي عبد القادر
نسبيا يعني لان هنا في هاتاي حيث اتواجد
هناك حركه كثيره للاليات الكبيره والضخمه
التي بدات تعمل على ازاحه
الركام في المناطق المتضرره والمباني التي
سقطت ولذلك لم نعد نفرق بين الهزه الارضيه
او مرور شاحنه فكلما كان هناك نوعا من
الصدى الكبير نشعر وكانه زلزال جديد او
هزه جديده فهناك نوع من التعود ليس علينا
فقط
صحفيه ولكن حتى على من يتواجدون في هذه
المنطقه طبعا تشاهد خلفي بعض الحركيه وكان
يعني تبدو وكانها من الوهله الاولى تبدو
وكان الحياه عادت الى طبيعتها لكن هذه
الحركيه كلها مرتبطه
بالزلزال الزلزال الثاني خصوصا هنا في
منطقه دفنه بهاتاي هذا هو مركزها وهنا
حدثت او حدث الزلزال الثاني
امس مساء اول امس الذي بلغت شدته
6.4 على سلم
هناك استنفار كبير هناك حركيه كبيره
لاحتواء تبعات هذه الزلزال الجديد الذي
ادى الى سقوط باقي البنايات التي كانت
متصدعه وكانت قد تحملت نوعا ما يعني تبعات
الزلزال الكبير الذي ضرب المنطقه عموما في
السادس من فبراير الماضي هناك خيام منتشره
في كل نقطه تقدم المساعدات هناك انتشار
امني كبير من مختلف التشكيلات الامنيه
التركيه من جيش شرطه درك في مختلف محيط
هذه المنطقه وبالخصوص عند محيط المباني
الحكوميه شاهد
من هذا الجانب بعد تمثال سليمان اتاتورك
مؤسس الدوله التركيه الحديث الذي يبدو انه
صمد في وجه
الزلزالين الكبيرين الذين
المنطقه لم يسقط تمثاله وبقي شامخا فوق
ذلك المجسم في حين ان المباني الحكوميه
خلفه تضررت بشكل كبير هذا مبنى البلديه لم
يسقط كليه لكن اجزاءه داخليه كلها سقطت
وتبعثرت اوراق ووثائق ومستندات المواطنين
في هذه المنطقه خلفه بنايات اخرى حكوميه
كلها صارت مستويه على الارض ولاحظنا كيف
ان كل الوثائق والمستندات والطابعات
بالحديث عن هذه المباني متضرره الحديث عن
اعاده الاعمار كان قد بدا ياخذ حيضا حيزا
كبيرا في حديث المسؤولين الاتراك في
الايام الماضيه لكن بعد الاخير والهزازات
الاخيره والتخوفات من هزات المقبله ايضا
هل من تطورات في هذا الملف
قد يكون الموضوع سابق لاوانه وهذا ليس
كلامي وانما كلام كثير من المسؤولين
السياسيين هنا في تركيا قد يكونوا معارضين
طبعا
للسلطه الحاكمه والائتلاف الحاكم هنا في
تركيا لديهم من
المبررات لكي يقولوا اعاده الاعمار سابق
لاوانه في هذا التوقيت على الاقل او حتى
قبل ثلاث اشهر التي ستلي هذه النكبه لانه
حجم الدمار كبير جدا يحتاج مبدئيا او ازمه
احتواء يعني
لمساعده المتضررين هذه هي الخطه
الاستباقيه والاستعجاليه التي يجب التركيز
عليها لانه حتى مع نصب هذا الكم الهائل من
الخيام لكنه ليس حلا الجو بارد والطقس صعب
جدا والظروف صعبه لهؤلاء الناجيين الذين
يقطنون هذه الخيام نحن قضينا ليله في
العراء مثلهم داخل المركبه السياره قد
نكون اوفر حظا مقابل من يبيتون داخل تلك
الخيام لكن الجو بارد وقار جدا ظروف
الحياه صعبه كنا صباح اليوم عند بزوغ
الشمس تجولت في تلك المخيمات رايت اطفالا
من شده البرد يعني خدودهم ووجوههم صارت
متشققه صار لهم تشققات في وجوههم تحدثت مع
بعض الاولياء يعني يحكون بانه هناك امراض
قد تصيب ابنائهم وبداوا يشعرون بامراض في
اطرافهم وكل شيء فهذا يتطلب تدخلات
انسانيه عاجله لنقلهم الى بيوت على الاقل
البيوت المجهزه التي كان اعلن الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بانه سيبلغ عددها
حوالي 100,000 في غضون الى غايه شهر مارس
اذار المقبل ربما تكون هذه الحلول التي
ستنقص منها معانات هؤلاء لكن الخيام
التي عاشوها الاسبوعين الماضيين اعتذر منك
عبد القادر هذا ما سمح بالوقت شكرا لك من
هاتاي متابعنا العربيه عبد القادر خربوش
ارتداديه متواصله مشاهدينا اذا اخرها تلك
المسجله هذا الصباح في البحر المتوسط
الهزات تثير الذعر السكان حيث تقع حتى
البعيدين عن مكانها لكن ما طبعت هذه
الهزات وهل يمكن ان يلحق هذا زلزال اخر
اقوى كما تقول التحليلات المتداوله
اتجاه تصاعدي تتخذه الهزات الارتداديه
التي اعقبت زلزال سوريا وتركيا عددا وقوه
حيث وقعت اكثر من سته الاف واربعين هزه
ارتداديه وصلت قوه احداها ل 6.4 درجه اي
بمثابه زلزال اخر هذه الحقائق اضيفت الى
تحليلات تهويليه وتنبؤات بان الهزات هي
تمهيد لزلزال اكبر واقوى لكن ما هي الهزات
الارتداديه وهل فعلا هناك زلزال اخر متوقع
اكثر تدميرا وفق خبراء جيولوجيين كلما
كانت الهزه الاساسيه قويه كلما تبعتها
هزات ارتداديه اكثر على مدى اطول يمتد
احيانا لاياما واسابيع وحتى اشهر فعند
وقوع زلزال قوي يتحرك قسم كبير من الفالق
الزلزالي المسبب ولكن ليس بالكامل
وبالتالي القسم الذي لم يتحرك سيواصل بعد
الزلزال لحين عوده الارض الى طبيعتها وهو
ما يسبب الهزات الارتداديه خبراء اكدوا ان
بعض الهزات لم تكن ارتداديه بل هزات
مستقله حدثت على فوالق اخرى نتيجه ضغط
تسبب به الزلزال الكبير على ما يحيط من
فوالق اما التحذير من امكانيه وقوع زلزال
اقوى فاحتماليته ضعيفه وفق علماء بحكم عدم
اتصال الفوالق لا سيما ان زلزال القوي
الذي ضرب قبل اسبوعين حرر القسم الاكبر من
الطاقه الضاغطه فيما القسم الاخر ينتقل من
مكان الى اخر ويحدث الاهتزازات
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نواصل نشرتها
من تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث تستعر
المعارك الشرقا في اقليم دومباس قبل 48
ساعه من الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع الحرب في
هذا السياق كشفت هيئه الاركان ان الجيش
الاوكراني صد اليوم هجمات روسيه قربه
بالمقابل هاجمت قواعد مؤقته للجيش الروسي
واستهدفت منصات انظمه الصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات هذا وخلف القصف الروسي على خرسون
امس خمسه قتلى و16 جريحا على الاقل وفق ما
افادت اداره خرسون العسكريه
من جهته طمانه محافظ مدينه ماري بول
السكان بان نظام الدفاع الجوي الروسي يعمل
بشكل جيد وجاءت تصريحاته بعد سماع السكان
في المدينه دوريا في جارات ليلا محافظ اكد
ان النظام الدفاع الجوي صدى هجمات دون
وقوع اصابات او اضرار كما قال
ونشير هذا خبر عاجل موسكو تقول ان هجوم
الكترونيا اعطى رسائل غير صحيحه بقرب وقوع
هجمات جويه على مناطق روسيه وسنوافيكم
بمزيد من التفاصيل
وقال في خطابه الليلي انه لم يطرا اي
تغيير على الخطوط الاماميه رغم الضغط
الكبير من جانب القوات الروسيه
هي تلك الوارده من دونيسك
قواتنا تتشبث بمواقعها على خط المواجهه في
شرق اوكرانيا ضد الهجمات الروسيه المستمره
والتي لم تتوقف على الرغم من تكبدها خسائر
فادحه من المهم جدا ان نذكر انه لم يطرا
اي تغيير على الخطوط الاماميه على الرغم
من الضغوط الكبيره التي تواجهها القوات
الاوكرانيه واشكر جميع مقاتلين الصامدين
في الجبهات الاماميه
وفي رد على انتقادات قائد مجموعه فاجنر
بشان بيروقراطيه العسكريه نفت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه التقصير في امداد قوه
المتطوعه في ارض موفيس
البيان انه في غضون يومين فقط تلقت
الوحدات القتاليه المتطوعه
1660 خليفه صاروخيه لقاذفات الصواريخ
المتعدده واكثر من عشره الاف قذيفه
للمدافع ذات العياء الكبير ومدافع الهون
كذلك استلم 980 قطعه ذخيره مخصصه للدبابات
واكدت دفاع روسيا حنا جميع طلبات الذخيره
التي تحتاجها الوحدات المتطوعه خلال الشهر
الجاري سيتم تقديمها خلال الايام المقبله
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اليوم محادثات
في وارسو مع اعضاء مجموعه بوخارست تسعه
والتي تضم دول الجناح الشرقي لحلف الناتو
ومن المقرر ان يجدد الرئيس بيض خلال
لقاءاته التاكيد على دعم اوكرانيا في
مواجهه روسيا وعلى دعم بلاده الثابت
الجناح الشرقي في حلف الشمع الاطلسي
مجموعه بوخارست 9 تضم اعضاءا في حلف
الناتو من شرق ووسط اوروبا واغلبها دول
كانت تنتمي الى الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا
ووسط الاتهامات المتبادله بين واشنطن
وموسكو واكد رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وخلال
وجوده في بولندا اكد انه الولايات المتحده
والدول الاوروبيه لا تسع لمهاجمه روسيا
مضيفا ان الحرب في اوكرانيا غير ضروريه بل
غير ضروريه هو رئيس بوتين هو من اختارها
اتحدث مره اخرى مع الشعب الروسي الولايات
المتحده والدول الاوروبيه لا تسعى لمهاجمه
روسيا وبالنسبه لملايين المواطنين الروس
الذين يرغبون العيش بسلام فان هذه الحرب
غير ضروريه بل هي تراجيديه اختارها الرئيس
بوتين فهي حرب من صنعه المساله بسيطه على
بوتين ان يتوقف عن غزو اوكرانيا وبذلك
نصدل ستار الحرب
هذا هو يعقد حلف شمال الاطلس والاتحاد
الاوروبي واوكرانيا اجتماعات متواصله تهدف
الى تنسيق عروض الدول الاعضاء من الاسلحه
والذخيره وفق الاحتياجات التي قدمتها
المصادر الرسميه في الكتلتين الاطلسيه
والاوروبيه لا تخفي الصعوبات التي تواجهها
قوتها في تامين الذخيره اللازمه التي
تحتاجها اوكرانيا
في الاجتماع الثلاثي الاول بين حلف الناتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي واوكرانيا اكدت الاطراف
الثلاثه على اهميه اسرعي وتيره تزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الثقيله والذخيره لصد
الهجوم الروسي المرتقبي
بعد عام عن اطلاقه الغزو الروسي لا نرى اي
مؤشر على ان الرئيس بوتين يعد للسلام بل
بالعكس ومثل ما اكده اليوم فانه يعد
بالمزيد من الحرب الدول الغربيه حسمت
مساله تزويد اوكرانيا بدباباته ليبارل
الالمانيه
البريطانيه وابرامس الامريكيه لكنها تواجه
صعوبه حقيقيه تتمثل في نقص الذخيره امام
خصم يطلق 50 الف قذيفه في اليوم حسب
المصادر الاوروبيه
اتفقنا على العمل بصفه مكثفه للاجابه على
ثلاثه اسئله كيف يمكننا تسويق المنتجات
العسكريه بصفه فعاله كيف ننتج وننظم بيع
الاسلحه والذخيره وكيف يمكننا نقلها الى
ارض المعركه مصدر وزاري ذكر ان كيف طلبت
تزويدها بمليون قذيفه كلفتها تبلغ اربعه
مليارات يورو دول الاتحاد الاوروبي تتشاور
فيما بينها حول امكانيه تمويل الاتحاد
عمليه انتاج الاسلحه والذخيره الحربيه على
الصعيد الاوروبي عمليه معقده وغير مسبوقه
نبحث امكانيه اسراع وتيره نقل الاسلحه
والذخيره من دول الاتحاد الى اوكرانيا
وتتولى اليه صندوق السلام الاوروبي دعم
اوكرانيا منذ بدايه الحرب وقد بلغت
مساعدات الاتحاد والدول الاعضاء العسكريه
لاوكرانيا 12 مليار يورو في العام الاول
من حرب اوكرانيا زودت دول الناتو قوات
اوكرانيا بكميات هائله من الذخيره جزء
منها سحب من الاحتياطيات الاستراتيجيه لكل
منها
وتتوجب الان اعاده تشكيلها امام الدول
الغربيه اسابيع قليله لنقل الدبابات
الثقيله الى ارض المعركه وتوفير الذخيره
اللازمه عمليه معقده قد يصعب تنفيذها في
وقت وجيز يعد فيه الطرف المقابل اي روسيا
هجوما واسعا نطاق حسب تقدير المصادر
الرسميه هنا
نور الدين الفريد العربيه بروكسل
هذا هو عربه اوكرانيا على لسان سفيرها في
باريس عن املها في ان يزور الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون في مارس المقبل لكن مصادر
دبلوماسيه فرنسيه اكدت ان ماكرون لا يريد
زيارتك افخاذ بل يامل في الذهاب اليها
حاملا وسائل دعم ملموسه
عبر رئيس مجلس القياده اليمني رشاد
العليمي عن شكره للسعوديه بعد ايداعها
مليار دولار في حساب البنك المركزي وقال
ان السعوديه صاحبه رؤيه مسؤوله تجاه اليمن
ولا طالما ساندت اقتصاد بلاده وخففت من
معاناه شعبه
بدوره اشاد رئيس الوزراء اليمني معين عبد
الملك بالوديعه السعوديه مؤكدا انها ستدعم
جميع مؤسسات الدوله اليمنيه واضاف عبد
الملك في تصريحاته العربيه حان الوديعه
السعوديه ستسهم في تحقيق الاستقرار النقدي
وستدعم قدرات البنك المركزي اليمني لوفاء
بالتزاماته واشار ايضا الى ان اليمن يواجه
تحديات كبيره في ظل التهديدات الارهابيه
للميليشيات
في ملف محاكمه رئيس حركه النهضه في تونس
قرر قد التحقيق بالقسم القضائي لمكافحه
الارهاب مواصله التحقيق مع راشد الغنوشي
حيث سيمثل غدا الخميس امام القضاه بتهمه
لقاء عناصر بتنظيم انصار الشريعه الارهابي
مره اخرى يمثل امام قطب القضاء لمكافحه
الارهاب راشد الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه
بتهمه جديده تتمثل في استعماله كلمه تاغوت
وهي العباره ذاتها التي كان يستعملها
تنظيم انصار الشريعه الارهابي المحظور في
تونس عندما كان يؤذن احد انصار النهضه
طاغوت التصريح واضح لكن الغنوشي يسر على
ركوب صهوه الهروب الى الامام
استهداف السياسي للمعارضه
ويتم بملفات فارغه لا تثمن ولا تغني من
جوع
الغنوشي متهم ايضا بلقاء عناصر من تنظيم
انصار الشريعه الارهابيه اما المخطط قد
يكشف عنه البحث عند مثوله الخميس المقبل
امام قطب مكافحه الارهاب القضايا المرفوعه
ضد الغنوشي وغيره اعتبر التعافي للسلطه
القضائيه تعافي القضاء سيفتح بابا لكل
لبحث كل القضايا العالقه وهذا سيحتاج الى
الكثير من الوقت لان القضايا الارهابيه
ليست قضيه سرقه موصوفه يمكن ان يتم بتسب
اثباتها على سارق وبالتالي تحتاج الى وقت
هزيج الجهد وتشهد تونس موجه ايقافات لعدد
من المتورطين في قضايا فساد وتامر على امن
الدوله تنظر دوائر القضائيه المختصه
في انتظار استكمال تحقيق معه بوصفه
المسؤول الاول عن العشريه السوداء ومهندسه
ما رافقها من احداث وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
تجري الصين واليابان اليوم اول محادثات
امنيه رسميه بين البلدين منذ اربع سنوات
الدفاعي وقدرتها العسكريه في منطقه
اليابان والعلاقات العسكريه بين الصين
وروسيا والاشتباه في استخدامها لمناطيل
تجسس وكانت اليابان اعلنت في ديسمبر
الماضي انها ستضاعف الانفاق الدفاعي على
مدى السنوات الخمس المقبله اما الصين التي
زادت الانفاق الدفاعي
العام الماضي فتنفق اكثر من اربعه اضعاف
ما تنفقه اليابان على قوتها
قال قاضي المحكمه الجزائيه في نيويورك
جوردانز ان ضحايا هجمات الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر لا يحق لهم الحجز على ثلاثه
مليارات وخمسمائه من اصول البنك المركزي
الافغاني
محكمه امريكيه تعلن انه لا يحق لضحايا
هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر الحجز على
اصول البنك المركزي الافغاني
السماح للضحايا بالحجز على ثلاثه مليارات
وخمسمائه مليون دولار من اصول المركزي
الافغاني سيكون اعترافا بان طالبان هي
الحكومه الشرعيه في افغانستان
الدستور يمنعني من الاقرار بان طالبان هي
الحكومه الشرعيه لافغانستان لان اداره
الرئيس جو بايدن لا تعترف بها
هذا ما صرح به قاضي المحكمه الجزائيه في
منهاتين جورج دانييلز
حجز الاصول المملوكه للبنك المركزي
الافغاني يتطلب الاقرار بان طالبان هي
الحكومه الشرعيه في افغانستان
وكانت اربع جماعات دائنه قد رفع الدعاء
وقضائيه ضد عده اشخاص وكيانات وحصلت على
احكام غيابيه
وفي ناحيه نشر مشاهده نذكر بعبرز العناوين
هزه بقوه اربع درجات فاصله اربعه في اعماق
البحر المتوسط يعتمد صداها في تركيا
ولبنان والاراضي الفلسطينيه
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه تؤكد صد هجمات
الروسيه عنيفه قبل يومين من ذكرى بدء
الحرب
نهايه هذه النشره المشاهدين شكرا لحسن
المتابعه وكونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]